let's talk about Queen Elizabeth and why
her death after 70 years on the throne
has revived debate about the British
Empire
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great Imperial
family to which we all belong
her State funeral was on a scale that
none of us are likely to ever see again
yeah very momentous occasion it really
is I mean the amount of dignitaries that
are there
it wrapped up 10 days of national
mourning where about a quarter of a
million people lined up for hours to pay
their respects
I think it's been nice to say thank you
to a woman she's done having to stand in
line in the queue for likely 14 hours
really not that much you know in
comparison to what she did she was so
much a part of our lives that
um there was something solid and so weak
and safe knowing she was there I think
the the depth of feeling and the extent
pretty astonishing but at the same time
there are other conversations happening
too about the role and relevance and
responsibilities of the British Monarchy
and how much the Queen's Legacy is tied
up with the complicated and often
violent history of the British Empire so
for me it's always been about looking at
the monarchy Through The Eyes of
colonialism I think that her Legacy is
one that will become more and more
complicated as as this moment recedes
and the world steps back we're in
different lenses they have different
perspectives on the past on the colonial
past and the queen becomes this person
where all of these sentiments get
projected onto half fairly or unfairly
so what is the connection between the
queen and the Empire how did The Empire
change under Queen Elizabeth and what
could all this mean for a successor King
Charles
foreign
now the thing about Queen Elizabeth is
that her Reign spanned both the Empire
and the end of that Empire Queen
Elizabeth drives to her coronation when
she ascended the British throne in 1952
she also became monarch of more than 70
territories around the world most of
these became independent countries
during the first 20 years of her Reign
but by the time she died she was still
The Head of State in 15 countries known
as the Commonwealth Realms which include
the UK Australia Canada and several
Caribbean Nations the queen straddled
this boundary right between the colonial
period and the postcolonial period of
decolonization so that's what makes her
so interesting the British Empire goes
back to the late 1500s over the next 400
years it became the biggest empire in
history everything you see here in Red
by the 1920s it covered one quarter of
the earth's land with territory on every
continent except Antarctica more than
400 million people lived under that
Empire and at the center of it all there
was always the royal family the British
royal family and the British crown is
the face of British imperialism those of
us who study Colonial history know that
whatever colonizers did they would
always invoke the king they would always
invoke the crowd as justification for
what they were doing and that's why
Queen Elizabeth's death brings up these
big questions about what happened under
the Empire how she was connected to it
and how that history is still playing
out today I think her passing reopened
certain
conversations that people thought were
closed uh it will open settings
resentments I think it brought back
memories of some of the more atrocious
and violent things that were done in the
name of the British royal family and the
British crown not only the use of
enslaved labor then we have the
expropriation on a large scale male of
indigenous populations land and the
claiming of their sovereignty which
really marks the 19th and 20th Century I
don't think it would be right to say you
know the whole empire was wicked because
I don't think that's actually true
the Empire has a very checkered history
um it's it's
would be a caricature to say that it was
holy evil just as it would be a
caricature to say that it was wholly
good there were all sorts of complicated
consequences often unintended now the
queen only occupied the throne at the
very tail end of the British Empire and
some people argue that that distances
her from some of the worst parts of
colonial history plus there's a big
focus on how Queen Elizabeth oversaw the
dismantling of the empire
but that period known as decolonization
was also violent in many places you know
that dissolution was not this kind of um
this benign peaceful transfer of power
it was 30 years the first three decades
of her reign
was marked by recurring brutal violent
end of Empire Wars for example the
British fought brutal military campaigns
against pro-independence groups in
places like Malaya now Malaysia in
Cyprus and also in Kenya
and what happened there is something
people have been bringing up a lot
British forces used brutal tactics
including torture and detention camps to
suppress a violent Uprising by a
pro-independence group known as the
maumau what you find is that this is a
story of systematic violence and torture
um on an extraordinary scale that
torture was taking place between October
of 1952 and 1960 during the first eight
years of Queen Elizabeth II's Reign
after a landmark court case in 2013 the
British government apologized and agreed
to pay around 23 million dollars to more
than 5 000 Kenyan victims apart from
compensation
one of the objectives in bringing this
case was for these veterans to be
acknowledged
as Heroes they are fighting for justice
so let's be clear some really awful
stuff happened during Queen Elizabeth's
Reign and that leads to the question of
whether she should be seen as
responsible in some way one thing to
keep in mind is that as a constitutional
Monarch her role was symbolic she was
not allowed to intervene in political
matters to what extent was she
personally responsible well
in a sense not at all I mean the queen
did not direct government we did not
decide what colonial policy was
um was she responsible as the head of
state well yes in a sense she was in
that the state itself which she embodies
was responsible for things that were
done under its control so you know the
I'm afraid the answer is a bit
unsatisfactory it's yes and no so then
it comes down to what the queen did do
and what the world saw her do and a big
part of that was Building Bridges with
former colonies attending Independence
Day ceremonies and making countless
Royal visits even though these days
people may question the Optics of some
of those trips
and then there was the Queen's
commitment to the Commonwealth which she
was the head of it's basically an
Association of Former British colonies
although other countries have also
joined she was simultaneously the face
of the British Empire and all the
brutalities and all the theft and all
the terrible things associated with it
but at the same time this very nurturing
video that people in many African former
African colonies of Britain could look
up to could even admire you know they
would see her displaying the graves and
and Poise and this this nurturing caring
attitude she went to Ghana and she was
dancing with my my bed in president
croma a few part of the royal family you
see that Duality you see that complexity
uh playing out as people try to remember
her Legacy and long Legacy and now that
the Queen's gone it's down to King
Charles to deal with that complexity
which also comes with pressure for some
things to change the debates over the
role of the monarchy and the legacy of
the British Empire aren't going away if
anything they're getting louder
[Music]
last year Barbados got rid of the
British monarch as its head of state
from this moment every Barbadian becomes
the living embodiment of the new
Republic
the Prime Minister of Antigua and
Barbuda recently said they plan to hold
a referendum on it
there's talk of Jamaica doing the same I
think that there is no high heightened
Consciousness about the role of the
monarchy and the need to put an end
to that relationship that we've
perpetuated for far too long colonialism
is something that didn't just happen at
three four five hundred years ago it's
something that's still affecting all the
countries that they invaded now the
world in which
King Charles is Imagine as King in is
radically different from the world in
which Queen Elizabeth was Queen and so I
think in that sense he's going to have a
much harder time uh sustaining that
image of the British royal family as the
this this institution that unites the
formerly colonized and this humanizing
nurturing institution of solidarity
there are also calls for the British
government and other institutions to pay
reparations as a form of redress for
what happened in the past and for King
Charles to apologize something many
people are disappointed the queen never
did nobody is going to say well you know
she should have rejected being queen or
she could have abdicated but haven't
become Queen I think she reigned a
particularly significant moment in human
history
when she could have used that platform I
think she could have wielded her moral
power she could have deployed her
enormous symbolic Authority
to shift the terms of the conversation
um should the king apologize I think
that's something that we can look
forward to discussing probably over some
years but I think you know that um it
would it would please some people it
would displease other people that's the
thing about all of this there will never
be a consensus and how you view these
issues comes down to how you assess and
interpret history and everyone's going
to have different takes on that but the
death of Queen Elizabeth II and the
accession of King Charles III brings the
debate into a new era
check out this playlist to watch all our
other start here episodes and don't
forget to subscribe to this channel so
you don't miss our next one
[Music]